okay it's time for the mailbag we do
receive about uh i don't know a few
hundred emails a day but each week i
will highlight eight to ten of them and
go over them with you sometimes there's
interesting things sometimes there's
nice compliments sometimes there's toxic
attacks and pejoratives a little bit of
everything you can email info at
davidpakman.com but make sure you have
something really substantive to say um
one person who did not have something
substantive to say in any way
is this person who actually sent us a
message via facebook who said you sir at
least they're being polite you sir
are a vile and disgusting piece of s
your views and opinions are treasonous
and you should be locked in an effing
looney bin
alongside biden and his [ __ ]
vice president
this i guess
is
well
this is a lot of different things
and i guess it's also misogynistic among
i mean we can't say what other what what
else it is um but it is very unhinged
we get hundreds of messages like this
every day
and one of the really
important things that we should remember
is you know when people email me and
they say politely
david don't you think you should do more
to bridge the gap
between left and right so that we can
kind of get people on our side and in
our way of thinking yeah i'm for that
when someone disagrees about the degree
to which business should be regulated or
what the tax rate should be or how far
we should go in mitigating climate
change
please those are
you know perfectly reasonable
disagreements policy disagreements where
we can have a conversation and each
person explains where they come from and
we might be able to
change people's minds or have productive
conversation at minimum
the person who sent this message
you can't have that conversation with
them there's nothing i can do to bridge
the gap with this person other than to
throw myself at their at their feet and
say
i'm so wrong about everything i believe
and you're so right and i'm such a as
this as this person says a vile and
disgusting piece of whatever
there's some of these people are so far
gone
there is no way to bridge the gap and so
we've got to go around them we they're
not going to be with us they're not you
no matter what tone i adopt on this
program
this person is not going to have
productive conversation okay next email
from jane
about the outdoor ski resort mask policy
in canada jane said i don't think you
criticized the lack of masks at the
indoor state of the union address or the
fact that california lifted its indoor
mass mandate on february 16th but you
did complain about the maskless
snowboarder in ontario do you honestly
think there's a qualified non-political
scientist who thinks masks should be
mandatory outdoors at this stage for
vaccinated folks you claim to follow
scientific advice but you choose to
disregard it when it doesn't suit your
narrative
um listen
what on earth are you responding to
ma'am
i made clear when we looked at a video
of a dad throwing a tantrum and having
to be grabbed by five security people on
an outdoor ski lift i said in that
he went there knowing that was the
policy i have said almost since the
beginning of the pandemic it started
with
i don't know that we really need masks
outside and then we had data and then i
said
we definitely don't need masks outside
unless people are literally on top of
each other in you know insane situations
i've said it from the beginning and
indeed
the state of the union the rules were
you don't have to wear a mask so jane
this isn't about
my opinion about when masks are and
aren't necessary i've already said i
don't think the masks outdoors are
necessary because that's what the
science has shown
the dad humiliating himself and his
family throwing a temper tantrum because
he wouldn't wear a mask the problem is
he's acting like a like a little kid and
he knew the rules
if i don't want to wear a mask somewhere
like let me give you an example
at gyms
for the entire pandemic you had to wear
a mask
regardless of whether i thought it was
necessary and i basically did for the
most part
um i don't want to wear a mask while
working out so you know what i did i
cancelled my gym membership i'm not
interested in working out and being on a
treadmill with a mask on but if i choose
to go to the gym and i know what the
rule is i'm gonna abide by the rule the
guy on the ski lift knew what the rule
was and he ignored it that's the problem
it's not about my opinion about masking
thorkl wrote in and said
jonestown was not a mass suicide
criticizing me i welcome it this is at
least the second time you talk about the
mass suicide at jonestown it was not a
mass suicide you could maybe call it a
mass murder-suicide but many argue just
be a mass murder people were forced to
drink the drink and those who refused
were shot calling it mass suicide sounds
like everyone did it of their own free
will yeah this is fair i should call the
jonestown massacre
a murder-suicide there were a bunch of
people there who willingly took
the uh flavor aid or kool-aid or
whatever it was
because they had been brainwashed they
did take it willingly some did not and
some were shot the children were
forcibly injected with it i will do i
will do better thorkl
and i will refer to what happened in
jonestown with jim jones in south
america as a mass murder suicide
i appreciate the correction
walter rhoden said biden will pardon
trump
and nobody's talking about it
um
i don't know about that
uh i don't think trump's going to be
charged with anything
so for that reason i don't expect biden
to pardon trump but i know that at times
past there has been this
idea in the united states that
we don't go after former presidents
criminally and so we have seen pardons
but uh joe biden has given
no indication that that's what he would
do now maybe walter knows something i
don't or maybe walter's speculating or
whatever the case may be but i have no
reason to believe that joe biden
would would pardon donald trump if you
were charged i don't think trump's going
to be charged with anything as i've said
before
haley wrote in
could putin have dementia
she asks hey david long time fan of your
show in one of your latest videos you
talked about putin being possibly
terminally ill and that being a reason
that he's attacking ukraine do you think
it's possible putin has dementia he
seems to be overly suspicious of ukraine
in the west like he is paranoid of
everyone what are your thoughts on this
there's no way i mean listen
delusional paranoia is sometimes a
symptom of dementia
uh
sometimes they really are out to get you
uh sometimes some combination of both i
we there's just no way to know and i
understand when you see these pictures
of putin
um at a 50-foot long table away from his
own advisers you think well either he's
really afraid of germs or he's sick and
whatever or he thinks one of them may
try to kill him and that's paranoia but
i have to tell you it doesn't seem
completely unwarranted i mean it's
conceivable maybe somebody would try to
kill him i don't know
so i think haley as much as i appreciate
the the hypothesis or the idea
i just don't think
i don't think there's any way for us to
know right now
and it may be the type of thing that we
could know in retrospect at some point
in the future
scott wrote in about the alt-left
and says i'm really glad that you're
being authentic and speaking your mind
against all sides
that are counter to your ideas
ideals
keep up the great work and i look
forward to seeing your show continue to
grow yeah you know i've received a bunch
of emails recently from saying david i
really appreciate the courage to call
out other leftists that you have first
of all i don't really think that they're
leftists to be perfectly honest like
when i look at tulsi gabbard
what is there that's left i mean she
she's vaguely against wars but like so
was trump supposedly you know um i
this is not a program
where things are off limits or we have
sacred cows or whatever i just call
things what they are and it just so
happens that with the russia ukraine
situation
a lot of these so-called leftists are
saying very strange things and so i'll
tell you when i when i see that
andrew roden
about the word anomaly
david i am a geologist who works in an
industry that deals in a lot in
anomalies i am going to lay down the law
and proclaim your original pronunciation
is correct the correct version begins
sounding like the word anonymous if
anyone wishes to disagree with me i
challenged them to a game of mario kart
now listen i i have to tell you i'm
getting a little sick of the anomaly
anomaly thing
go to the merriam-webster dictionary
type in the word a-n-o
m-a-l-y
and you will see in the pronunciation
section both pronunciations are fine
anomaly like a garden gnome anomaly
anomaly both are fine and quite frankly
i'm getting a little sick of having to
defend that fred wrote in about russian
covid david i hear so much about the
russian invasion but one thing that's
not mentioned what's going on with covet
and russia and is it or could it be an
issue has russia solved the pandemic and
need something to fear or is the ukraine
invasion a distraction from covid no i i
don't i mean listen
uh there's there's still covet in russia
there is
no reason to believe that we've gotten
accurate data from russia from the
beginning
and i don't think it's transparent what
is happening with kovid in russia but
russia has not solved kovid but it seems
completely reasonable that like most of
the world not all of the world but most
of the world
there has been a three month two month i
guess
a decline in coveted cases and
hospitalizations and death i would
assume that's what's going on there but
i don't have any particular reason to
think that covet is quote over in russia
and i don't think the invasion of
ukraine has anything to do with covid if
you have a different perspective
certainly let me know reminder we are
launching the david pakman show coaching
this is a little this is an interesting
new project we're doing
i am going to try to help others
grow their online platforms so
if you are already a content creator
okay if you're not this isn't for you
this isn't to teach people how to start
if you are already a content creator and
you have a youtube channel with an
audience or a podcast with an audience
and you're all good on the production
side and you want to participate in some
group coaching
i am going to be coaching four
maybe five people in a group format
you can sign up at davidpakman.com
coaching you have to be willing to have
our coaching sessions filmed because
then we're going to publish them
to hopefully help even more people okay
that's the idea
if you're not interested just don't do
anything i got two emails from people
angry
and they don't want to do it but then
don't sign up
if you if you don't want to be coached
on growing an independent media platform
do nothing okay but if you want to be
you can go to davidpakman.com coaching
fill out that form we've got a great
bonus show for you today coming up right
after this short break sign up at
joinpackman.com
to get access to the bonus show
otherwise we'll see you on monday